e
♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est ici que le 17 juin 1972,
cinq personnes s'introduisent
dans l'hôtel de luxe qui
prétendent être plombiers sont
en fait ici pour installer des
micros afin d'espionner
la direction du parti démocrate.
Et c'est dans cette chambre
qu'un des proches conseillers de
Richard Nixon séjourne afin de
pouvoir surveiller la tentative
d'espionnage qui a lieu
du parti démocrate.
On découvre alors que
sur les cinq cams s s s s s s sn
de la CIA. Le cièèème n'est
autre que le chef de la sécurité
du président Nixon.
1972 est une année électorale
et, dans la culture de
la fin justifie les moyens.
poussé ses proches à faire
des choses clandestines
contre les démocrates.
- L'atatatation de
ces cambrioleurs est bien vite
rapportée par deux journalistes
ererererererererererererererere,
qui vont creuser vraiment très
profondément dans cette sombre
Aussi profondément que dans
ce stationnement souterrain
de Virginie, où les deux
journalistes vont recevoir
de la part de Deep Throat,
Gorge Profonde, un informateur
très myst
Scoop après scoop, le scan
grossit et met en évidence
l'implication de la Maison-
Blanche et du prppppppppppppppp,
sa réélection.
, , , , , affaire classée?
Pas du tout.
c'était que la culture
politique va craquer.
Mais pas en 72. En 73.
- Face à un président
qui nie tout en bloc.
Le Sénat vote alors
à l'unanimité pour lancer
une commission d'enquêteparlemet
15 mois, va fasciner, mais
aussi dégoûter les Américains,
qui vont suivre les audiences
par dizaines de millions.
Ils vont en apprendre davantage
sur les saeeeeeee
fomentait la Maison-Blanche.
Alors que Nixon s'empêtre dans
le scandale et consent à faire
démissionner deux de ses proches
collaborateurs, tout le monde
se pose la question : que
savait-il vraiment et depuis
quand était-il au courant?
Sur ce point, à cause de
sa paranoïa et de sa certaine
culture de l'illégalité,
le président Nixon a c
à sa propre perte.
- Mais c'étaient
les enregistrements qui
ont montré que non, Nixon...
Nixon a menti.
Il était menteur!
Il a fait partie de
toutes ces activités.
Sans ces enregistrements,
on aura seulement le témoignage
des gens proches de lui.
♪ ♪ ♪
(sirène de police)
- Sur les neuf enregistrements
exigés par le juge, qui veut
aller au fond des choses,
la Maison-Blanche en fournira
sept, mais sur l'un d'entre eux,
il manquera 18,5 minutes
de conversatio
Le juge de Washington
ira jusque devant
la Cour suprême pour obtenir
ces dos.s.s.s.s.s.s.s.s.
Pendant ce temps, l'étau se
resserre puisqu'une commission
judiciaire de la Chambre
des représenta
7000 dépositions afin de
préparer la procédure de
destitution du président
américain.
La Maison-Blanche
perd alors sa cause
devant la Cour suprême et doit
fournir les retranscriptions
des minutes manquantes
des enregistrements qui,
décidément, incriminent
clairement le président Nixon.ls
disaient au président :
"C'est fini", le président
lui-même savait que, s'il reste
à la Maison-Blanche, il va
s s s s s s s s s s au Sénat.
(applaudissements)
- Et donc, le 8 août 1974,
unl'l'l'l'l'l'l'l'l'l'histoire
américaine, Nixon démissionne
et quitte la Maison-Blanche
le lendemain.
Nixon a beau faire le "V"
de la victoire quand il part,
c'est d'abord et avant tout
une victoire pour le travail
de la justice
des deux journalistes qui ont
mis au grand jour le scandale
qui a sali la réputationisisisi.
Au fait, qui était
Gorge Profonde? Il faudra
attendre 2005 po
qu'il s'agissait de Mark Felt,
le directeur adjoint du FBI
à l'époque de l'administration
Nixon. Il l'aurait fait
pour des raisons éthiques
et personnelles.
Alors, que reste-t-ildudududud?
Notamment, le fameux suffixe
"gate" de Watergate,
qu'on utilise depuis
pour qualifier les petits et
gracacacacacacacacacacacachent
la réputation des politicien